[Musik]
bringen wir bitte einen champagner ja
dinge etwas zu feiern
nein ich habe nicht nur gerade an eine
besondere begegnung erinnert ich hätte
auch gern schöpfern ertrinken du trinkst
geworfen sagt ja ist ja gut ich meine
schön wenn jetzt ein
[Musik]
oh mein gott ich habe gleich und ich
glaube ich auch vor vielen vielen jahren
bin ich von zu hause weggegangen
ich habe nicht nur meine arbeit verloren
ich habe mich verloren so gab es nicht
mehr nur noch schlag nur noch lieben nur
noch unterhalten und dann kannst du
dinge
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich mal
nicht mehr brauche
aber es ist soweit ich will heimkehren
[Musik]
ich bin nie wieder lügen und nie wieder
jemandem wehtun vor allem hier nicht ich
wünsche mir nichts mehr als mein leben
mit dir zu verbringen
[Musik]
ich liebe dich
willst du meine frau werden
ist der champagner bezahlt
ich glaube die rotter
und ich wünsche mir auch seine frau zu
werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]